- Well, I love painting the
maps because it gets me out
in the weather like this.
(camera clicks)
It's pretty awesome to come into a resort
and look up and see my map.
(enchanting music)
I'm James Niehues, and
I've painted ski maps
of some of the biggest
resorts around the world.
I've painted 194 different maps.
This is North Star out at Lake Tahoe.
And a Mexico ski area.
Then we have Snowbasin here in Utah.
This is an image that skiers see.
They judge the mountain by the trail map.
You want to portray the
mountain as beautiful as it is.
I was a advertising
agency man for awhile.
In 1987, I painted my first trail map.
They used my map.
I loved it right away.
I could paint and do a little travel,
and learn how to ski.
Whenever I get a call from a resort,
the first thing that I'll
do is scope out the mountain
and see what I've got to work with.
I work heavily from aerial photography.
Or I'll go up in a plane, I’ll
take a pan across the whole
mountain in a shot.
From this, I take it back to the studio
and I get on my computer
and select the ones
that I want to work from, print 'em out,
and then I reference all
the material that I can get
and start my sketch.
What I will have to do is manipulate
the different elements of the mountain
and get it on a single plane of paper,
on a single page.
(bright music)
What I like to do is show the skier
what he's skiing through.
And help the skier identify
where he is on the mountain.
For a large ski resort,
it'll take me three weeks
of painting, but that doesn't
include all your prep work.
So realistically, it'll
take me three months.
Do I have a favorite mountain?
Wow, I've done a lot of them.
And a lot of really exciting mountains.
There's a lot of things that
I love about doing this job.
I get to fly in some of
the most beautiful spots
in the world.
I'm gonna keep doing
this as long as I can.